three two one go we hosted the world's
first ping pong bounce contest and the
last person to drop their ball wins one
thousand dollars
this first one is out oh no
oh no oh there's another one out oh no
you can do it
no no it's my personal best
three players have already been
eliminated the atmosphere is very
concentrated I know are you confident
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna win but it's
it's surprisingly you have to focus
you're gonna hear the sound for a week
what happened I was thinking what I
would do with the prize money but I will
never know people were dropping out one
by one but we will start giving them
different distractions so the longer
they bounce the harder it gets good
efforts just [ __ ] my finger I feel like
I'm starting to get good at this yeah
and before things get more exciting we
want to show you today's sponsor
wondershare filmora we've been editing
videos for several years and have to say
filmora is one of the most beginner
friendly editing softwares out there
literally anybody can start using it
even with zero editing skills and it has
so many different functions for example
these built-in animations took just a
few minutes to add to this video to make
a super cool edit there are loads of
built-in templates like texts overlay
filters to help you edit videos quickly
[Music]
went for an evening stroll and I lost
the ball
oh
thank you players are dropping out like
flies we haven't even introduced the
special rules the best thing about
filmora is how easy they've made it to
add Advanced edits to your video for
example the speed ramping feature is
just a simple tool that will get you a
clean professional edit some other
features like this are the super easy to
use motion tracking feature and a
massive library of different effects and
transitions you can also make these same
edits if you try a filmora's free trial
it will create a watermark on the video
but make sure you follow them on
Instagram and comment to have a chance
to win a free license huge thanks to
filmora for sponsoring this contest
let's go see how they're doing
I wouldn't
you're counting to 100. I have done like
four times hundred okay so six minutes
gone and we're at 400 bounces for how's
it going over here focused dancing in my
mind this should be Olympic sports this
one is the most relaxed I think
he's out
oh I see some dance moves it's almost
easier if I don't focus on this too much
you really think so well it's going
pretty well how's it going
quite good
[Music]
I think when it was that boy here it
wasn't me we are we are showing
currently footage of the illegal
movement here so I don't believe you I
want to see the footage
I was set up but that would be nice if
you come to training no that would be
nice to get new players yeah I love it
friends being made during the tournament
this is lovely and if you want to do
something lovely today you can click
subscribe to help us reach 5 million
subscribers
it's not as easy as you think oh no you
need to focus a lot it's more of a
mental exercise
don't mind me you're doing great
I can watch the camera all the time if
you want to yeah you can do this
but we have a challenge for you if you
can do a behind the back we will give
you 50 euros whenever you're ready
very impressive this guy just won
himself 50 Euros so we'll just you know
I'll have any Pockets yes
[Music]
it's okay well here you go thank you at
least you got 50 euros that's good thank
you you just go bounce bounce bounce
behind the back and continue 50 euros
come on dude okay okay let's go
no
[Music]
we've had a dropper there's one less
player
[Music]
intestines
it's focused but I still feel really
good about this I feel like I won myself
that's the most important thing ah we
got another drop out I had to go out
because it would have been up there for
the others yeah of course of course yeah
try one uh back on that
50 euros no it wasn't 50 euros that one
so we have 12 players left and it's 25
minutes gone we're coming up with some
sneaky challenges to make it more
difficult okay guys when I say go you
need to sit down and turn the gum back
off the last person to get up on their
feet gets eliminated
oh oh he's keeping it he's keeping it
what a save we got one out we got one
out
let's try thank you
thank you we don't even have to check
the replay who was lost because we got
the one out 11 players left okay we'll
let you relax for a bit that's for a bit
you think you're gonna make it I would
like to go to sleep now you got good I'm
starting to get a little hungry I do
have any snacks yeah we can bring you
some snacks we have a hungry contestant
so we will bring them food you look a
bit bored
follow me
oh
we've got another Dropout oh no
no
my eyes were tired and then I lost my
focus but it happens sometimes like I
have the cramps yeah same same actually
I have tried it a few years back and I
got 30 minutes 30 minutes
no another one
yeah because I speak with guy oh no so
someone was flirting with you and you
got distracted yeah what a cheeky mood
my guy here went to flirt with the girls
and she got distracted
I'm sorry
no but now you can go and talk to her
and like nobody's gonna disturb you
banana delivery
she's got the banana
oh
vehicle where's my pizza
let's make the circle smaller yeah this
one's going to be an easy one we're just
making the circle smaller just like in
fortnite yeah sounds weird people we
have a suggestion for you guys or the
next person to drop their balls we'll
get 50 euros the person after that won't
get anything you don't think you're
gonna win it now could be a chance to at
least take home 50 euros
nobody went for it
let's try this one add another 50.
so 100 euros 100 years
100 euros and the banana
okay so we're down to seven contestants
about the we've been going at it for 45
minutes
he's in the soul what is your favorite
color
I'm guessing yellow who's your favorite
tables player
good awesome thanks for the thanks for
the words well wish you all the luck
to break him
out there oh I should have taken 100
euros yeah you had a chance this is my
personal favorite requires some teamwork
it requires strategy and it requires
trust first you need to pick a pair
team number one attempting the ball
switch
okay
team number one clears the challenge
time for Team number two that was super
impressive
I think he did that on purpose I'm quite
sure
communication from my side if I win I'll
give him 25 percent
team number three
oh
no it wasn't an easy one you made it for
exactly one hour I'm glad that this
human exam is over
[Music]
it didn't work these guys are solid
can you keep going for another hour do
you think yeah but it's just boring it's
boring you heard some hot stuff we've
got to make some changes thanks Sam for
the next 30 seconds you have to lift
your leg Ready set go oh
[Music]
keep going keep going three two one and
normal
it's always sitting down oh nobody
dropped out let's go think of something
just so me and author wouldn't be the
ones deciding who gets through we have
brought two neutral players who have
dropped out earlier their faith is in
your hands oh God
no it's time
to slowly gather yourselves around the
three seats behind you
oh God now you can answer what is your
favorite color
it's yellow right yeah it's yellow that
means one chair less for the musical
chairs oh no okay so we are the final
three what are you gonna do with the
thousand Euros if you win I buy it
[Applause]
right
that's a very good investment all the
way from Norway yeah yeah he's got the
punk finity sense here okay that's the
secret it's a victory I trust you yeah
okay final three next phase musical
chairs awesome is just here we're
waiting
oh my God
I'm so nervous myself
[Music]
[Music]
oh
we have Sam the only one sitting on the
chair
[Applause]
s
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
purple
exactly one hour 30 minutes
congratulations
thanks for watching until next time
thank you for everybody for coming
[Applause]